first is much too early to draw any any
conclusive what went wrong is it from
turkey to the Netherlands of the Belgium
but it's exactly what we are working on
we are very active in trying to identify
all the stumbling block they might be
technical might be legal or maybe even
cultural and we're working heavily on
this only five countries as you know
share information intelligence
information about terrorism your job is
to coordinate and to make this country
do more what what can you do one way is
to make it public and that's what I did
if you read my latest report three weeks
ago I put on the all the figures in the
report and so I hope that it will bring
some member states to realize that they
need to do more we I think we see
progress in recent months if you see the
number of a left which have been shared
in the Schengen information system by
the security service it's amazing it
moved from 1000 to eight thousand names
so we are making problems we should not
be negative the Italian is to do it via
quickly that the European Union do
enough to protect its external borders
to detect foreign fighters were coming
back you mentioned the Shang and
information system is it fed properly by
the member sides so you're right to say
that we need to be much more systematic
at the external bowler hats of state and
government have decided to do so and the
legislation is pretty close to be
adopted that requires legal a change but
also requires equipment a connection in
all the island in Greece and trading and
I know that not only because of the
terrorist threat but also with the
migration crisis that all members some
of our embassies are providing a lot of
equipment to Greece to Italy and so here
too we are making progress it should be
stepped up and speeded up yes but I'm
confident that in the coming months will
reach a hundred percent check at the
exxon border
a lot of blame was put on Belgium in the
recent days aspersion a special case I
wouldn't say so people were referring to
Merlin bake but I heard a a French
minister saying that they were several
Merlin begging froze and by the way
yesterday someone with an arsenal of
firearms was arrested in france he was
French so we should realize that it is a
worldwide threat it's it may happen in
Germany may happening in Britain it does
happen in Turkey in Lebanon in Jordan in
Egypt so we're not alone in this version
and France are now trying to dismantle
this current network of terrorists what
about the threat is the threat and over
it's still existing no unfortunately my
assessment is that the more we will put
pressure on daesh in Syria in Iraq and
we are winning in a way you've seen the
recent progress in PAL me in Iraq in
Syria sorry the more we do that the more
will c dash may be trying to mount
attack in the west and especially in
Europe it is an organization which wants
to show successes and for the time being
they are on the defensive another
consequence might be the return a bit
earlier than we had expected of many of
our foreign terrorizes all citizens who
went to fight alongside dash in java de
nuestra a tournament one could be a move
from Syria to Libya of the leadership of
dash so I think the Treach remains quite
high and quite acute indeed